yeah welcome to the computer vision
study group again
um today uh I want to talk about the
paper that is
um well not that new but well it was
released in summer but it was only now
accepted to the new Europe's conference
which is happening in a few days right
so if you're in Europe's by any chance
you might come across this paper
the full title is caused to find vision
language pre-training with Fusion in the
backbone
that is a really long title so they said
okay in short it's fiber
so I'm the mostly refer to it as fiber
right because the whole title is just
too long
um and as usual with my presentations I
sort of a little the same to go with the
whole thing and
um for this one I actually chose
Pokemon right
so let's start with a little intro
so first the Titan screen right
the good old Pokemon title screen you
might know from your old days
uh
and let's jump in
so this is hack trainer and he wants to
become the best Transformers trainer of
the whole world
because who doesn't want to be the best
Transformers trainer of the whole world
right
currently he's on a mission to become
the champion of the vision language
League
so he has already trained some really
powerful Transformers and in his current
team are
Al death and deter clip
and over so of course these aren't real
Pokemon right you probably have never
seen one of them it's actually papers
that are in a similar domain as fiber so
they're all Vision language papers
and to create these visuals I use the
diffusion model that you can find the
space on how you face as well there was
um published by Lambda Labs I guess
if you have time you can look at it in
the end but yeah you will see some of my
Creations in the presentation it was a
lot of fun
um so yeah back to the intro
but there is a wide range of strong
opponents in the vision language League
for example Vision question answering a
visual question answering image text
retrieval image captioning object
detection phrase grounding
and referring expression comprehension
all right so again
um
I guess you've never seen this before
but
I had good fun creating all of these
it's just hard to remember which one is
which actually something like wait which
one was it so yeah
let's see so hacks turns almost really
good he trained them though but
something was still missing right so
the Transformers are good but he was
looking for the one that could beat all
the tasks
so he went on his search
you know he was searching far and wide
across the land and everything uh or
across the web right so he was going to
all the resources now like our Chef
papers is code Twitter maybe now
Mastodon and he went to conferences
right just some of them here like new
ribs uh triple AI ICM iclr and one day
he found it the legendary Pokemon that
could solve all the tasks I just showed
or Transformer it's not a Pokemon it's a
Transformer right I might mistake that
sometimes and here it is
fiber so that's that's a fiber
Transformer visualization
and fiber now can battle all these tasks
right so this is a visual question
answering
um image captioning image text retrieval
phrase grounding
object detection
and the big one referring expression
comprehension
I was able to remember what they are
yes he beat them all
and now finally with the help of fiber
hack was able to become the champion of
the vision language league right so
yay he made it
great
so much for the little intro
I hope you had fun I had fun creating it
it took a long time but I had fun and
now let's look at the paper right so
like really that is the paper the the
front page of the paper
um maybe it's a short uh
note on the authors so here's a Ce do I
hope I pronounce it correctly and
Aishwarya kamat
uh and yeah say gun
and actually Aishwarya is um
a bit known to me because she already
published The Amp debtor paper
and uh
right before
the session now like a few days ago I
wrote a mail to her her and asked if I
could have a look at the code of fiber
because there is a repository as you see
here but there's no code in there yet
and and she was super nice she was like
yeah sorry there was some internal
problems with Microsoft and releasing
the code but she hopes it will be up by
the end of the month so hopefully in a
few days maybe in time for new ribs
um and she also sent the code to me
actually to have a look at it and that
was really nice and really helpful for
the whole preparation here
so thank you Aishwarya if you're
watching this
and I hope I don't uh talk stupid things
here that are not right about the paper
then Aishwarya can correct me
but yeah let's start
so let's first look at Vision language
pre-training and the traditional
training right so we start with like
traditional training
um you have two classes right you have
Pokemon and you want trainers and then
you would just want to classify so what
you do is
you get your neural network which also
diffusion creation
I love it actually it looks so nice uh
like a real neural network for me
and you drain it so it charges up right
it gets all glowy and stuff
then you can query it for example the
Dragonite and you hope it gives you the
class Pokemon
that's like yeah you're one of one of
the training image classifier for
example
so let's have a look at Vision language
pre-training right
I called it like the new way even though
it's not that new but uh well the
different way
so you have like an image for example
the Charmander in a tree and then you
have a text to it which describes the
image so a commander standing next to a
tree
you put that in into your neural network
it loads up right it's trained now and
then you can query for example how many
tremenders are there and hopefully it
will tell you one
great so that's something you just
learned from a lot of these pairs it is
seen right it has understood like Ah
that's a Charmander and how many are
there I find exactly one
okay
so we can go a bit more sophisticated
right so like a cool Charmander with
sunglasses standing next standing to the
left of a tree
that is already a bit more sophisticated
in terms of the text
and another task that you could do is
say like okay I want to get a caption
and then you hope to get the same thing
out or something quite similar at least
um and yeah
captioning right but we can go even a
step further now so we've got the cool
Commander now it's a cool Commander with
sunglasses standing next standing to the
left of a tree which caught fire
oh how could that happen right uh
now what you can do is you can draw
bounding boxes and actually say like
okay here's a cool Commander use
sunglasses here's a fire and he is a
tree
so we enriched the information of it
right we've got like the text we've got
bounding boxes and we've got the image
and that's actually really helpful
because now we can do some crazy things
for example oh yeah we load up the
network of course the Transformer and we
can query okay give us fire and
sunglasses right and then you get the
Bounty boxes of fire and the sunglasses
which is really nice there's object
detection
just there from like yeah these pairs
um
last step after this we're done with
vision language free training so now
there's another Commander right a
Charmander right of a cool chamanda with
sunglasses standing to the left of a
tree which caught fire
so again oh this time it's already
trained
um and bigquery the Charmander right of
the cool Charmander
and hopefully we will get this
Charmander bunny booked out so it
learned that there's this Charmander
right of the cool chairman right that's
actually what is referring expression
comprehension
the big boy Transformer
that was too fast
so these tasks I just showed right we
can say like okay there are two
categories like Image level and region
level and Image level stuff like visual
question answering image captioning and
image text retrieval so these image
leather tasks are stuff where you don't
need the Bounty boxes right you don't
need the fine craned
um
Define grain information that the
bounding boxes give you you just really
need like the image and the description
of the image now for reach level tasks
you will need actually these bounding
boxes so you can do stuff like phrase
grounding
which is really similar to object
detection all right so yeah a referring
expression comprehension and even stuff
like zero shot object detection so you
can
detect objects that you have not really
labeled so it's zero shot
never seen before but it can still give
you
these objects
so this brings us now to fiber
fiber itself has like this two-stage
pre-training setup
that is at the core
so the first stage pre-training actually
takes care of the the image letter tasks
right and the second stage pre-training
also called the Define craned
pre-training or course Grant and
fine-grained this one is for the more
region of the tasks right the more
fine-grained tasks so to say so here you
only get like the input image text go
into fiber
and you get um you use some stuff like
your image text contrastive loss mask
language modeling and image text
matching
um and when you have trained this first
stage you can do stuff you can fine tune
and then here
do stuff with vqa image captioning and
image text retrieval right so on the
second stage
actually you can then when you have all
this information
you put an object detection head on
Fiverr
and then you can find you in this
pre-trained thing and you can do stuff
like General object detection and phrase
grounding so here you can see a bit of
the difference between object detection
and phrase grounding so for object
detection mostly you just like put in
single words right like person bicycle
tent whatever and for phrase grounding
you have like a whole sentence and then
from this sentence
um the Transformer just looks what it
can find in the image
so just yeah a bit more natural in a way
this phrase grounding
but of course you have a look a closer
look at the whole thing now
so um the whole architecture
in itself so you can see it a bit uh
simplified over here right so there's a
vision
Transformer and the language Transformer
and in their modules actually that's one
of the most important things is a
cross-attention module so as Vision
Transformer they use swin as a backbone
I will tell you later why exactly and
for language they used Roberta
actually they never really mentioned why
they use Roberta but they just use
Roberta okay it's good enough for their
cases
um yeah and now they cross attention is
as I said quite important here because
most other Transformers that I showed
before that I also in the vision
language stuff right they are using
cross-attention or they're using doing
the fusion between those two
Transformers after the whole uh yeah
attention stuff basically so after
they've trained everything in the layers
and they have the embeddings they then
fuse that stuff like as a head a fusion
head
but here they're using it right in the
backbone right so you get self-attention
over there from language and
self-attention from a vision to the
language
and they say okay but this cross
attention actually it is flexible it can
be switched off so for example you can
say like yeah
for this task we don't want cross
attention here we just want it here or
we don't want cross attention at all so
they they build a mechanism where you
can actually control if you want to use
cross-attention at all or not
um and yeah we can have a look here like
for the tasks what they did so like for
vqa and visual reasoning tasks they use
cross attention
for image text retrieval actually no
cross attention at all so it's just like
a dual encoder you just get a vision
embeddings and language embeddings in
the end
for image text retrieval and captioning
is actually quite interesting because
they say like okay we take like the last
the output of the last layer really of
the vision Transformer and use that as
an input for the cross-attention modules
in the language Transformer which makes
it a kind of a sequence to sequence
model and that works pretty well for
captioning
and you have object detection and
grounding it's actually similar again to
the visual question answering right they
just use cross attention
uh everywhere basically thought the full
cross attention setup and the object
detection had on the vision uh Backbone
in the end
so just overview again right you see the
difference is now in this
things
uh yeah
so how does this gating mechanism
actually work right how do they turn it
off and on so first
they've got this cross attention right
you just
um calculate it with a query key and
value as usual
and then they actually have a parameter
called Alpha and Alpha is a learnable
parameter
and it controls this cross-attention
thing by being multiplied with the whole
Matrix right so when Alpha is zero it's
off whenever is more than zero we have
above zero basically it's on right and
when it's on it just gets added to this
whole feed forward thing
so I think the next year the next slide
is just I just did from creating like
this
on off on off you can just click on it
and then do on off on off here for more
than zero it's on Alpha equals zero is
off so
yeah
not much more value in these slides but
you can play around when you have a look
at the slides make sure to to click on
the button
okay
now we look at the the course
pre-trading stage
that fiber uses so as input for the
course pre-training they just take a low
resolution image because for the task
like these Image level tasks you don't
really need a high resolution image
because you don't really care about
details so you can just take a low
resolution image that helps you doing
training right
so you've got your fiber Transformer
right here you get get your low
resolution image feed it into the fiber
Transformer the fiber Transformer
charges up again
right now it's drained and what you get
out is there's a question answering
captioning and image text retrieval of
course it's the really high level
so I mentioned before they're using like
these three methods
and let's go through them so this image
takes contrastive learning mask language
modeling and image text matching
let's start with the image text
contrastive learning
just really short there's nothing new
they just use it like because it worked
in other papers right they said like
okay we use that because it it works
pretty well actually
um
and why they are doing this um I put
this Alpha here which says that here the
cross attention is actually turned off
so while they're doing the image text
contrastive learning they don't have
cross attention used in there
uh in the
backbone basically fiber
so image text contrastive learning is
really just okay you have your your
matching pairs like spiritual commander
and a Bulbasaur and then you have like
double the amount of negative samples
and now what you want to do is that you
want to minimize the distance between
these pairs
between the positive Pairs and want to
maximize
the distance between the negative pairs
so when you have embeddings for like
division embedding for the Squirtle and
tax and banks for Charmander these
embeddings should have like uh far
distance right they shouldn't be too
close together
but when it's a squirtle and a squirrel
it should be close together
makes sense I guess
so next step mask language modeling I
think that's also pretty well known
here they use the cross attention
actually
and we have a sentence for example
Blastoise is the best Pokemon ever
which is of course true
and
not ready to discuss
yeah
what check is that no
uh sorry I just dipped in the chat
and yeah so you've got these tokens then
they say okay we mask 14 15 of those
tokens
which is well when you have six tokens
it's about one token that is masked yes
the masked one
actually today I learned about the
English name for these ones it's
unknowns I think I just know that in
German there's a Cognito but in English
apparently unknown so The unknown's Mask
this token here
and then you just like learn to predict
the token right and yeah mask language
modeling I think a pretty well known
concept
and the last one image text matching
is similar to image
takes contrastive loss I would say so
you have like three texts again
exclusive the commander and as good with
sunglasses right and now you want to
kind of classify it
so this one
and this one is that like
a true match or is it a thoughts match
so true or false and then you just yeah
learn to predict this stuff
if it's true or false kind of binary
classification
and what they're doing they are doing an
hard negative mining so they want to
find like examples like excretive
sunglasses that is pretty close to a
squirtle
in in semantic terms and for that they
actually go back to the contrastive or
they learn stuff the learn distribution
from the contrastive loss and look for
pairs that are close together in this
contrastive loss but are not the same
right so that's how they mine for our
heart negative examples and how they
improve
um this image text matching in general
okay that's it for the course craned
pre-training and we can go to the Fine
free training
so for the fine pre-training we actually
taken high resolution image as input all
right because we want this region level
tasks so it's beneficial to have a
bigger resolution higher resolution
and feed this into our fiber right there
so fiber charges up again
now it's strained but if we also put our
object detection head on top so that's
the object detection head right here
yeah
you could think of it as like a mask
going on here right and from this object
detection head we then get a phrase
Crown we can then get phrase grounding
zero shot object detection and referring
expression comprehension
okay so this object detection had
actually is a piece of its own so it's
yeah
it is kind of special I would say
because it's really like in the code
um it's actually mostly in musk or CNN
module
and yeah so you might have an idea what
it's doing already
and and to give another over a few of it
uh it's a bit of a closer look at the
object detection head so from fiber we
get
text aware image embeddings actually
right because we have cross attention
turned on our image embeddings that we
get in the end are text aware and we get
image aware text embeddings so the other
side it's like the the text Transformer
output and here's like the image
Transformer output but because there was
a cross attention already in the
backbone they already know a bit about
the other right
and now they go and say like okay we
take our text aware image embeddings and
throw them into a feature pyramid
Network
which is a pretty common thing for doing
object detection
um yeah which just helps to
to look at the image basically at
different scales right and that's also
why they use spin as a backbone and not
for example the vanilla bit because swin
is doing this hierarchical
uh analyzes and giving you basically
this hierarchical input that you need
for feature pyramid Networks
and then they go and use a dynamic hat
which I just learned about uh by reading
the paper
it is basically oh it's like detector so
just detecting the objects really
but it incorporates some attention
modules
so um I have my notes somewhere let me
check my notes I wrote it down yeah so
it has this scale aware attention
spatial aware attention and task aware
attention right it's like these these
three steps that it uses
um for the detection in the end
and apparently it works pretty well
and in the end it gives you localization
so like a centerless loss and a general
intersection over Union loss
and then in this case they get the
grounding score
so the grounding score consists of
actually the the embeddings from these
regions here
I'd say like yeah just a
image or the embeddings of the regions
right and they get the image aware text
embeddings they do dot product between
these two metrics multiplication you
know
this stuff and then yeah you get your
grounding score actually
and that's what they optimize
and I'm doing this they can do all these
reaching level tasks you've seen before
so there is no more
or they do fine tuning of course
on special tasks but yeah that's really
all there is to the pre-training now
and yeah there's some more details of
course I mean as machine learning people
we might be interested in this so for
the course pre-trading as input size
they use like a 30 384 times 384 image
later in for 100 000 steps uh with a big
batch size of 4096 on 64 a100 gpus
and use a Adam W as Optimizer right
so fortifying trained pre-training they
have a bigger input as mentioned it's
800 times 1 333 pixels
and they train it for 800 000 steps uh
batch size is a bit smaller 64.
um but they are using 64 V100 gpus
so it's oh it's done in Microsoft
research Labs right so they can afford
like 64 a100 in V100 gpus
probably you can't do that at home
unless you're rich really rich
but yeah
I know just no thank you
fun fact it's like one point times five
faster uh training than clip which is
one of the contenders because they're
using this embedded cross attention
why select such a weird input size is a
question in the chat that is a good
question I also asked that myself
um
yeah I can't tell you why it's 1 333
maybe they they did some hyper parameter
optimization and one of the parameters
was the input size and then in the end
it turned out that 1 333 is the best
size
they don't really uh speak about it more
maybe somewhere in the appendix I
haven't studied that in detail but not
in the general paper
so yeah
but it is a good question it's still
open
if the authors ever watch uh the video
maybe they can comment on you on YouTube
and tell us
okay
so that's the details
now we can look at results actually
all right because I've done all this now
and uh yeah how good are they actually
right so here's some some benchmarks for
visual question answering and image
retrieval tasks so the first ones are
um there's a question answering if I'm
not mistaken
and the second or like the last ones
here are the image retrieval ones image
retrieve that text retrieval
and yeah you can see like fiber down
here fiber B so they are only reporting
um the the B side the base model size
actually in the paper so they use spin
base and they're using Roberta Bass
and um yeah the B train is four million
images which is comparable to these up
here
right and they create out some here
which have like a bigger model size or
have more input images
and then you can see that they are like
comparing to all the others here with
the same model size and everything they
are better in almost every task
they're not as good in the retriever
task actually you can see here
but there they say hey yeah we're not
that good but we're really efficient
like more efficient than most others
because they are using this this dual
encoder actually and apparently that's a
very efficient way and uh more scalable
than most of the other attempts and for
that they are still pretty good they're
not far off from the results here right
so when we look at bigger models
okay there yeah they even
better sometimes sometimes worse it's
all you know in general
um
after reading the paper the feeling okay
it's a good model it is like for its
size it's really good right that's
that's the main point is for being a
base size model it performs really well
and it has some features that makes it
more efficient than others
um it's not necessarily like ground
breaking or like setting new state of
the art everywhere that it competes
um but yeah it is quite Universal and it
is not that big as a base size model
so on image captioning data sets
um they actually also write pretty good
so it's like the the fiber base
standard thing and then there's
something called gold that they can use
to get better and then there's a cider
optimization
I have to admit that I didn't look too
deep into these
um captioning things like gold and
Insider optimization so I can't tell you
much about them if you have questions
about cider and gold
um well look it up
I'm pretty sure you can find stuff about
it and yeah
you can see that they're they get really
good when they have like gold and
Insider right so they are actually
um often
state of the art here
and yeah just performing quite well
and yeah again especially compared to
models of the same size trained on the
same amount of data they're just better
so
yeah but if you want to take like a
bigger models sometimes you get better
results of course
[Music]
uh sometimes not
you have to check right
so for phrase grounding actually that's
um one of the more interesting tasks for
me
um yeah you can see again right the
fiber base compared to some others like
mdeter and clip
and yeah they are again compared to the
same size models
there are better
and even compared to clip with a spin
large
model they are still
better in some cases not everywhere but
in some cases they are still better than
the large clip basically
yeah and this one is actually
the fiber without the course craned
Vision language free training so there
they only use
like pre-trained weights for Spin and
for Roberta and then right to the Define
current pre-training step with the
object detection head
and then they yeah
just uh try out how good they are
they're even a bit better at this uh
r810
thing then the pre-trained
with a fine creator with a coarse grain
so yeah
that's the results here
and then we have referring expression
comprehension right here
and again we can see
same story as before basically I don't
know I I don't want to repeat too much
uh maybe interesting is it's a ref Coco
G over here because that's like the the
extra long Expressions right so
um stuff is in ref Coco G is really long
expressions and they are really
really well able to handle these long
Expressions even better than than bigger
models here right these bigger models
especially uh over is quite a favor
oh not famous but I liked one in the
community and they're on these long
Expressions they are actually way better
than over
and zero short object detection
and general object detection actually as
well so here they say like okay the
first values for zero shot and the last
one is for fine tuning so that's like
when yeah the general object detection
thing fine-tuned right
and for zero shot they also report
really good really good values
uh especially here in the Elvis data set
it's called Elvis I never said Elvis
okay Elvis
um here's this average position on rare
objects so this R stands for rare right
and there they actually really really
good on this rare object
um even better again than the the large
clip
so yeah
that's that's the result I mean that's
looking at results it was a bit more
boring than the Transformer Pokemon
before I reckon but I guess we have to
talk about it yeah way too far oh yes
just an overview of like different
models right and different tasks we
talked about like pqa which we will
captioning crowning object detection and
if it's trainable end to end and then
you can see okay they can do all this
okay and fiber can do everything
so yeah it's like the others they often
can do three tasks two or three some
maybe even four
but doing everything
is really rare and fiber is like the
first one here I mean since it was
published in June maybe it's changed a
bit already
but um yeah at this point actually they
were apparently were the only ones
and thank you yes
that is the end
oh we can look at some spaces after this
um but yeah
first of all thank you and I just put
all the Transformer Pokemon I created on
this slide for you to look at again
so it's quite yeah
some
things here it's really a fun space
actually
and
we can also look at the space
I linked it right here
right and then I can open it I hope you
still see it yes you should see it right
because
um it's actually quite funny because
they're all the examples down here they
say like Yoda Ibraham Lincoln George
Washington whatever you know they put
like real names
and oh it is funny when you do it
because then it looks a bit like Yoda or
something
but it's also fun to just really throw
in paper names or something like yeah
that's the Yoda
so really when you throw an object
detection
at right then we say like okay maybe in
June 30 steps I will leave it there
two images generate image
it is pretty fun to create your own
Pokemon like that
see object detection head sometimes you
get lucky sometimes you have to run it
again
that's how diffuser models work in the
end right
um and yeah I mean there's some more
stuff you can check out here and here
but for now I mean if you have questions
feel free to ask them
again
or we can end this here
okay I mean if you have more questions
I'm still around in Discord you can also
like send messages also on Twitter
Mastodon whatever you want
LinkedIn
I'm not on Facebook anymore so not there
but yeah
feel free to contact me if you have
questions
well then thank you
and have a good day